with Allegiant who's going to tell us
about Krypton crypt analysis of
candidate program obfuscators thankfully
thanks for sweater
thanks organizer and six other
participants and all of you who are
watching us on youtube that you attend
this talk in such a difficult time in
our life and in some time in some sense
like this whole program also reminds of
us of rethinking the meaning of our life
what we are doing how can we do to
contribute to the human-being societies
to overcome this crisis I guess so part
of what we can contribute is to build of
to build up a sense of science and also
like I guess for this talk one of the
immediate implication would be a hold of
you in the shelter so you will not go
outside and hopefully this will bring a
little bit of joy to your life and also
more urban problems to be solved after
this talk so let me get started that the
topic of today is going to be crypt
analysis of candidate branch and program
office caters and at the same time I
would also like to remind that if you
hear a big noise like a don don don don
don it's not likely to be earthquake we
have a neighbor
they have two kids and practicing for
Olympics so you know I think this like a
switch of order program into online it
also gives the big opportunity to all
the participants like so if you get
roster during the talk right so you can
just a turn off your spring and the do
jumping jacks in the background and no
we we heard about it and you can come
back if you find something interesting
and also a you know like right now
everyone's in the home and you know
you're watching all the people also
working in the garden and you're also
thinking about like a throwback to Ty
and I would like to start this talk also
in the beginning of this new century you
know in the beginning of year 2000
everything exciting also it's very
exciting for the food of program office
kitchen because finally she has four
more attempts to define a program of
station the first attempts harder and
Baraka talked they tried something that
is later to show to be impossible but
there's one definition which is left
until now say in distinguishability
obfuscation so if two programs are
functionally equivalent
so maybe you can officer cater them
since they are computationally
indistinguishable it turns out this
definition survives and certain years
later we even have a candidate
of papers of candidates multi linear
maps and also candidate
indistinguishability office catered for
all circuits from basically candidate to
multilinear maps so you know this brings
the whole excitement to the field and
also adds a stage so they are called
candidate because at the moment they are
proposed we don't know how to base the
security of based a security of them
based on the problem we have studied
like we have some ideas that they can be
hard based on our previous understanding
of problems idea lattices but we don't
know how to build to the reduction we
don't know how to like analyze them but
assuming this multi linear map
candidates and IO candidates obscure
this opens like the whole imagination I
would say the stats the age of discovery
in the Krypton land again
so really what happened after chosen
setting and in a short period of like
three to four years we have seen that if
you assume this multilinear maps and the
program of station are secure or more
less iOS secure then you can show all
the crypto applications that we don't
know how to achieve before so this is
only a partial list and and at that time
we sort of think about IO as the central
hub of cryptography as this picture
indicates and at that moment we are also
thinking like so after you show so many
great applications are the multi linear
maps and the program of skater and
analyze this application at least secure
like it's the time to take a very
serious look at the security so I would
like to explain this br-2 connections so
first is the multi linear map to
obfuscation in the beginning we is the
first work of cogito is showing a
candidate okay so there are some
security
notices more works has to be done so
later I think too important work it
shows if the multi linear Maps chips I
do security you shorten what is that
ideal security mean it's sort of like in
kazoom the multi linear maps they are
working as good as what we understand
under piling a map from from Paris so
they are kind of ideal there's not many
corner cases so if the motolinia map
achieves that security then we can
achieve VBB obfuscation like it's almost
like saying I owe you can build from
that so also you can recur the
underlying assumption to concrete
assumption called multi linear subgroup
elimination assumption so the problems
that you can also build io so so
basically the morrow is if the motolinia
map Gooding is good enough then IO
exists so and that time the connection
from multilinear maps from lattices it's
still a big problem I think it's a trend
is still big problem so so after the
walk of cogito there are three more
candidates there are more or less spaced
our lattice is problems actually they
are all modified from the previous fhd
scheme that you can see the kind of like
like this is approximate GSD and this is
a more GSW we modified but we don't know
how to base the security on a concrete
lattice problem at that time and in fact
in 2015 we will already see attack that
check of John Condy used in study they
actually break the CRT 30 multi linear
maps in some setting so it already shows
a world sigh and let's go back to 2015
so usually when we talk about the
security of multi linear maps we think
about two benchmarks so one is to do a
multi-party non-interactive key
agreement from multi linear maps and the
the benchmark is IO so we can think
about making a list of the status ting
in in in this table like here is the
multilinear maps and here is the two
benchmark applications so in 2015 we
have already seen the CRT sitting at
least some Singapore case is broken in
most of these two benchmarks and a year
later actually most of the key exchange
are broken and the i/o candidates you
know there's a partial attack IO based
on tradition 13 and digits 15 is still
standing at that the moment and so if
you combine this with the previous
picture you know the attack on Io it
really puts a threat down all the
application we have shown in the
previous three years so you know there's
more Han insight on what is going on and
at that time you know in 2016 I was in
the middle of my PhD and you're thinking
so this is the picture you see in crypto
Dan and you are thinking about yourself
what can you do what can you do to
contribute to crypto and also in general
like we are facing different choices
every day in your life so I would like
also like to let the audience know
flashback so what are the choices you've
made in your life like four years ago so
you know people have to make choices
every day in the life and even for the
characters in the movie so let's look
back into a movie 1962 so the school
kids are asked by the by their
professors to write essays to describe
their favorite animals so one little
girl of eight chose a bird and let's see
what she says a bird is an animal with
an inside and an outside
if you remove the outside you see the
inside if you removed inside and you see
the soul
so and this is my choice at that time I
want to see the soul of obfuscation and
I think this is the choice of actually
many of the participants in the audience
and the outcomes comes in different ways
today I would like to take your suit
take you through a tour to see the soul
of obfuscation and I will continue of a
few more minutes as the overview of all
of skaters in the attacks an overview of
them and I will talk specifically about
two attacks that had worked out of
skater based our teachers 15 I will
later explain why do we focus on this
candidate and in some sense you know
explaining the technical details of
obfuscation her kind of difficult within
one hours but I hope I can give you a
brief idea and I would like to also
mention two interesting urban problems
each of them author he one of the attack
so it turns out these attacks are as
sorry as these urban problems are
extremely simple to describe even
without going through the obfuscators
but since they are motivated from them I
will still go through the tasks and at
the end mentioned so here's a problem if
you can slow it will make the attack
better so hopefully we'll have enough
time to discuss these two upper problems
so in the rest of the overview I would
like to talk about three things so so
really like the previous are also
overview so let me conclude the overview
by addressing three questions so how are
the other IO candidates doing right now
since we are going to talk about one of
them I would like to wrap up with Steve
others and also I would like to talk
about what are the general attack
strategies we use in the last seven
years of breaking iOS and multilinear
maps and
finally I would like to also tell you
why do we focus on Jeju 15 so so first
how are the other candidates doing so as
you seek and you can see from this
picture
previously we all know all the crypto
from bio and so you can see something is
turning into bring in its picture
because so after other text shows up so
we need all these applications to come
back to help aya and so this is really
like the picture backwards so right now
we are trying all the masses in building
oil and you can see this functional
encryption becomes a very big component
because right now you can also show
sixteenth functional encryption implies
back IO and right now actually this
branch is a very fruitful branch there's
a lot of attempts actually to build a
16th functional encryption in order to
show so that turns out to be showing
more chance of getting more modular
analysis so also I think all of them
what we understood at this moment we are
still exploring so also besides of
functional encryption multilinear maps
we also see a lot of new attempts in
recent year well there's also even
attempts like before 2013 there's a
proposal by Ryan Vinod of using black
box theater free groups so we know how
to do that either and or other attempts
so we are still in the distance long
sentence short we are still in the
exploration stage you know so this is
the big picture
are you Lee hi I have a question so here
you see that Astrix means not published
right and you have algebraic geometry
Astrix yeah so that means three linear
map there is a candidate we are still
trying to understand what's going on oh
that's cool
so that's like two years ago there's a
candidate then the first version is
broken then there's a desert version
which is longer so we're trying to
understand I mean is this on ePrint
so this is our archive I can send you
the link afterward okay all right also
okay so let me also talk about the
general strategies of breaking i/o so
you see there's a lot of ways to get I
Oh from the previous picture but the
general ways of breaking i/o there are
actually some common ports so obviously
to break i/o you need to find two
programs that are functionally
equivalent and a distinguished the
obscurity version of them afterwards so
you need to do that always step so some
other common strategies you use to break
I oh there it is
so we see very frequently that attack
strategy goes as follows so we are
trying to find equations or relations of
the unknown variables over the integers
or rationals instead of over the finite
field so in more general term we are
trying to move from a characteristic
cube field to like a coaxial
characteristic 0 or the base ring so the
basically intuition is the problems are
usually easier to solve over integers or
rationals we have more tours over there
the other obvious strategy is we need to
turn high degree equations into linear
equations and then looking ahead like a
in order the recent IO candidates and
their crypt analysis attempts who seems
to have many ways to prevent number two
meaning that we seems to have a lot of
intuition that so some equations we can
put them into high degree that it's very
difficult to linearize but one seems to
be
to prevent right now for all the noisy
based IO candidates because they are
still based on like the many of them are
still based on the crock tennis checker
by saying if an element is a big or
small / fq and therefore you can still
find the relations over the integers and
the cue if you watch the talk of amid
and others yesterday that you can also
realize so right now in the case that
well it's hard to remove we are actually
trying to find hard problems which is
even hard over the integers and the
rationals so that because this is a hard
to prevent if you use a noisy the new
and it shows I answer questions I see
okay
no I think you need not stuff like that
okay
so if you see interesting question that
remind me yeah yeah okay
so also in addition to the comma a
taxing strategy
there's also interesting attack
motivated by breaking IO or multilinear
maps that these are interesting attack
on specific components of obfuscation so
I know two big categories so one of when
one of them is a lot of lattice attack
that they can break virus of and true
that are motivated by multilinear maps
or fhg and the other big category is all
the sum of square attack like low-degree
prgs
so I think so these are very interesting
attacks that is motivated by brick Ivo
but also they have wider impact in terms
of it as to our target of crypt analysis
so finally why do we focus on digital 15
today well one of the reason is I think
so because we know right now we also
know a lot of safe modes of using the
digital 15 multilinear maps to do a lot
of stuff besides I
so we still don't know how to achieve IO
from a safe mode of digital based
analysis but we can use a safe mode
which is as secure as lwe to achieve
private constrained PRF and knock about
schism and trader tracing also from
direct construction so this is a
commercial so you can also see some of
my talks on YouTube about the safe mode
I'm not going to talk about today and
then upcoming today in the the other two
simon seminars about about lockable
station in a traitor tracing so europe
here would they recommend you to stick
into this channel so this is the end of
the my overview and the starting now
starting now
let me take you through the sole of
obfuscation and an obfuscation in a
sense of which is based on that Gigi the
Gaga top skater combined with digital
gauge fixing multilinear maps so you
know really the movie of saying you know
if you remove the outside you see the
inside and the you see the inside remove
the inside it's either so it's very
accurate for obfuscators because the
candidate ops catered from Gaga but also
in my point of view it has like four
layers and the if you unwrap layer by
layer we will see what's going on so for
the candidate Isle of Gaga or I see it
is building from a cursory steps so
first we need to find the right
representation of the plantiffs program
so if you have a C called Python code
you need to convert editing to a certain
format of plan text
so then I think of we add the three
safeguards so the safeguards we are sort
of thinking about them as used to be
used to randomize the plantiffs program
and the purpose is to prevent illegal
operations and the in the end after you
wrap it up with three safeguards we wrap
off them together with multilinear maps
you know one of your favorite multi
linear maps so we think about multi
linear map as the source of
computational harness so we're
essentially speaking multilinear maps is
not the only computational harness but
in this talk let's sink in this way so
multi linear maps we in the group
orbitals representation we think about
we encode or the element we want to
multiply into the exponent and multi
linear Maps gives you a way to compute
the product of them in the exponent
without revealing them in the clear so
let me start describing now and a
year-by-year so the first layer which is
actually the most important layer is we
need to fix a representation of the
plaintext program so to fix the
representation of Pentax program we use
parent in serum say suppose the program
we begin with can be de
that's born circuit so according to
barrington serum we can convert other
lakh depths boolean circuits into a two
expansion program so let me do you know
this is one of my favorite paper from
stock and Fox because literally the
probe is only one line
so here's Emily gave me a crypt Oracle
proof of how to represent a NAND gate so
suppose we want to represent an and gate
by a program which to subset product
computation so here's the way you do it
so suppose we want to do and gate
meaning like only if the two input wires
goes to one we output while at the other
case the output is zero so nice to use
identity matrix to represent zero and
then no identity matrix to represent no
zero and so here's the way you represent
all the programs so you say in one you
have a truth a lot of no identity matrix
is where P and a pink verse
corresponding to the first wire then the
Q and a converse a correspond to the
second wire so to evaluate you to the
sepsis Sun according to the input choice
so for example if the input is 1 1 you
do P times Q times P inverse times
converse and this gives no added in the
matrix so you can see all the other
choices gives identity matrix like oh if
you get 1 0 it will get P times I times
P inverse times Phi you get add an image
matrix so to bootstrapped end in to lock
type circuits so you also need or and
really it's a recursive composition so
you can convert a lot tabs boolean
circuit into the polynomial a long
branching program I would like to you to
remind this remember this picture
because this is actually the key of the
attack let's move on so
you convert everything into a branching
program for the purpose of putting them
to into multi linear map in the end we
think about we have a functional branch
where we have order like added in the
matrix and valid in matrix you can do
subset products in the end you compare
whether the product is equal to IR dot
so for the purpose of adding other
safeguards they also create a dummy
branch where order B Prime
I actually identity so whatever you
multiply is still identity and in the
end you will subtract them in the
compare we will see in a moment why do
we have a dummy branch this is for the
purpose of adding safeguards so now
let's start adding safeguards so the
first step is killing randomization you
try to glue things together you
randomize each matrixes they will cancel
out in the end so the second step which
will be the key to the one of the attack
I described is they add bundling scalars
to be read prevent mix input attack so
what is a mixing pot attack so if you
see the branching programs
representation like the first a bit of
the input can choose two steps in this
picture so what if you choose
inconsistent input between these two
steps so you can actually learn more
information about the program but just
to doing illegal computations so adding
bundling scalars with order cancellation
relation set up between the functional
branch and the dorami branch you can
prevent the rest rate from learning
illegal information from doing illegal
competitions may I have a quick question
yes please how do these two branches
interact with each other so so this is
can be described without other
safeguards so in the end the goal is to
say in the end after you wrap everything
up with multi linear maps you computed
by the following you do a subset product
in the functional branch and you do the
subset Prada
in the dummy brands and in the case
where the output is zero means at the
functional branch it goes to identity
then if subtracted the functional branch
and the dummy branch you will get to
zero so the zero test of the multilinear
maps will tell you a zero if not then
you'll get to render so you're saying
you're saying that they just run in
parallel so you just do the computation
on the main branch separately and that
dummy branch separately and you just
subtract them in the end right okay so
let me continue by describing the azan
safeguard so the last safeguard is a
another layer so we also had some
diagonal entries on the branching
program and then we add book is to
cancel them out so let's zoom in so here
is the original branching program and
like a permutation matrices so we are
two entries in the diagonal they are
random they're just to make the program
more random and in the end we have a way
to cancel them out by poking putting a
row vector in the beginning where this
is zero and put a column vector in the
end where this part is zero so you can
see after completing everything together
this random diagonal entries goes away
and in the end after putting all the
safeguards you rub of the program by
motor linear maps
I haven't described the multi linear map
construction but morally you can put one
of them on our side so
some of you has gotten lost because if
this is the first time you see a rough
skater
you've probably got hardly get lost and
they're probably doing jumping jacks in
the background so let me just give you a
quick highlight so if you get lost don't
worry you only need to remember two
parts the first part is remember the
representation of the Blendtec sprint
program we use permutation pension
programs and also the safeguard - we use
burning scalars so this will be the key
for the attack one of that tag describe
in a minute so let me continue by also
give you a recap of teachers 15
multilinear maps so I know I guess
everyone knows lwe what is doubly e you
have a public matrix and also an arrow
to be simple which is s times a plus a
little bit noise so the search audibly
problem says if I give you a in the Y
it's difficult to find s the decision or
W problem says is hard to distinguish a
and a y from random so in this talk I
would like you to use this graphical
notation so usually with this background
I mean the matrix is random with this
background like the white color
background
it means it's a small element or FQ and
there everything else which is unclear
at this moment will be put into the
unclear clock Connor
so what is the view of digits 15 so we
think about the multi linear maps in the
group representation as follows so all
the secrets are in the exponent of a
flock group where the discrete log
problem is potentially hard and tedious
15 provides a ring audibly and analogy
of this view so say instead of putting
all the secrets in the exponent of a
group I put all the secrets in the
secret place in the air debris samples
and hope there's a way to
publicly compute and then into the
lexical into the product of the secret
in the final yada be simple so the whole
point is how to find a way to map them
without revealing the secrets in the
middle so let me explain digit shifting
for one multiplication in two steps
so think about we are just are trying to
encode the secret s1 and s2 so that we
can multiply them without revealing what
they are so in step one will create a
debris samples with respect to the
public matrix of each of them so you
know if you out with them it will be a
no problem so in the second step we are
trying to connect these two samples by
building a bridge between them so I will
use the trap door of a I minus one to
sample a small matrix such that a times
a minus y times di equals 2y and in this
talk we will think about D 2 as the
encoding of s 2 D 1 as the economy of s
1 so let me first take you through the
functionality of this simple example so
record ago is two kind of like
multiplies them secretly and achieve the
product in the final really simple and
so right now just imagine the d1 entity
2 does not review s 1 and s 2 this is a
secret ago but Mexico's
the functionality first let's just open
them so we say a is zero times t1 equals
to the first edible sample and you can
write them separately multiplying t2 in
the last two again over a 1 times t2 so
a 1 times t2 equals 2y 2 and it opens up
to s 2 times a 2 and e 2 in the final
you can see that these parts is like a
small times more plus small times more
it's still relatively small and the
first part is look like the product in
the air doubly secret so this is a view
of the functionality of digits 15 very
frequently in the literature so
including a discussion candidate and all
the other safe stuff would be from digit
15 we use this subset product encoding
so I think you have to go as encoding
other secrets putting into the way that
later we all cannot compute a subset
product over the secret times a plus
more noise and the encoding of all of
them will look like a leading term a 0
and the U times like matrix with spirit
understand D or D choosing subset
products so we think about D as the
encoding of s and the in the end you
will choose how to multiply by the
importing the X the input is a big beta
string that choose which to multiply so
in the context of generate 15 plus the g
th r SW obfuscator this connection can
be viewed in the following way so we
think about order the previous version
program we have wrap up with safeguards
1 2 3 as the big secret term so this big
secret term is a it's not a big big in
the sense that they are baby nephew but
it's a it's a complicated secretin so
you put this secret current
into the corresponding position of the
secret turn of the table samples and
used to judge 15 to build a chain of
each import steps has two choices and
they put all the secrets into the
secrets of the gt-r script in check
so really the operation cross digit 15
or the program you will see is the
following we will see a zero and a bunch
of matrices as the functional branch so
this will encode the branch and program
wrapped by other safeguards in the air
doubly secret and you will also see the
dummy branch like there's also all
recordings in the dummy branch you will
see other matrices and this picture
except a a or you don't have to see it I
just want to point out in the end you
need to have a common area to achieve
the functionality alright so after
describing you know the construction you
ask thank you very much
so where is the soul of this off
schedule well in some sense of the sort
of top skater has already been described
basically to understand what's going on
I think half of the work you have to do
is to first understand the construction
and you know write it in the notations
that you are familiar with and explain
your own way in some sense but it was to
ask like what's the really you know that
the key point in the attack
so the key tag point in the attack we
need to use the weakness in digit 15 and
together with kind of some
vulnerabilities you exploit in the
previous three safeguards and plain text
in this talk the weakness will be in the
bank lines trailers and other plant
expansion program for different
candidates the weak points may be
different so right now let me
tell you the key idea behind the attack
to the multi-linear mark
so this is going to be I think the
probably the most important a few slides
from now in fact the key idea of the
attack to digit shifting it already
shows up in the work of Quran a call at
all to break the teachers routine based
key exchange so now look at your screen
carefully so if you do the honest
evaluation of just the two steps so this
is the encoding I described to you
before so you will see a big component
plus small components so the small
components are not a small random they
have structures so from now let's assume
s1 times s2 equals to zero so we say
there's a lot of evaluations in the
program of sketching context which goes
to all 0 and oh what you left is the
small component you can see eight times
the encoding times encoding equals to
the sum of two products which actually
holds over an integer
the evaluation mark you but the result
you get can be expressed into the sum of
two products over the integers if you
set up the variables over integers so
why is this observation useful let's
continue we need most place to see how
to rearrange this small component so we
rearranged in the way that we put order
the secrets and error corresponding to
the first encoding in the concatenation
of the first matrix as a kind of a row
matrix and the error in the encoding for
the second encoding into a column matrix
you know into this shape so you can
rewrite just to reorganize all the
components so right now the left becomes
coming from one coding and the right
comes from or the information from the
other encoding so still how do we
continue with the attack so right now
let's generalize a slightly so we think
about a we can get a lot of evaluation
in the following form so it's really a
times DX where there's a lot of choices
in the X part and if there's a lot of
choices in the Z part and you can do a
combinatorial an organization of a lot
of evaluations so let me be more
concrete so if we have more inputs at
the exorcism and the zeizel so we can
get more evaluations on w x y and z 1w x
1 z 2 they have we can combine them into
like think about there's n choices in
excellent and choices in Z so there's n
terms in many different combinations and
you put all the evaluation result and
form them into a matrix then you can
express the matrix into the the product
of two matrices and this relation or
host of integers
so how do we use this fact and to use
this fact that we can decompose into the
product we need to understand what is
the important information we want to
extract from these candidates so really
you know the matrix on the right hand
side you know it's all errors and
encoding the accordions are from cotton
distribution so right now we say they
are sort of redden and a small what
really we want to extract is the
information from the secret tail on the
left so this is still render but we want
to extract some information from the
secret tips so from now let's assume we
can write the big matrix as W so W is
you can compute from honest evaluation
and you can write it into x times Z and
Z is useless X contains useful
information and so here is a big picture
of the two attacks to the concrete of
station candidates so in C th17 what we
do is we collect a matrix W such that X
is kind of a twelve matrix and Z is a
square matrix and by computing the left
kernel of W you're actually extracting
information about the left corner of X
and this part contains information about
the secrets in the later attack we
actually do something much simpler we
just computed the rank above W and we
show this already reveals information
about dimension program directly so in
the rest of the talk let me briefly go
over these two attacks into details and
also explain to you the urban problems
so the first first let's pick two
programs which functionally equivalent
and as the target of the attack so we
think about the following two programs
so the first program have other identity
matrix you'll get all 0 outputs in the
end the second program has to know
audited program non-additive matrix run
in in two positions controlled by the
first input but you can see they were
canceled out in all the evaluations so
they are functionally equivalent our
goal is to extract the boundaries
scalars in the exosome so for example
the boundary scalars here and here so
then you can use the underneath scalars
to conduct the mixed import attack so
first let me explain how to get the
evaluations over zero so what you do is
you partition the evaluation the input
indices into the X part and the Z part
and for now let's assume they don't they
can be chosen independently so you get a
bunch of values for example at 0 0 0 0 0
0 I change the first a bit a little bit
then you change the second part
correspondingly it clearly relation yes
sorry there's a question you can read it
on your screen they are yeah the tactic
peasant of the relation on the noise is
not agree there are ways of making this
high degree that may avoid attack so
that's a good question so right now we
are maybe we can repeat the question for
the benefit of the recording okay yes so
in the in the previous slide I think
maybe the best place to start with this
here secret everyone can see the screen
so we think about
you know all the evaluations is
decomposing to the product so basically
it's a degree to relation and in this
simple example you can achieve you can
decompose into linear relations but
actually even for did just for the
Jewish Jewish I establish candidate if
you think about other entities are
repeating like one two three four one
two three four one two three four in
that extreme case it is already very
difficult to decompose into this product
so in some sense like I will show in the
end there will be one setting of even
the first candidate that even the first
candidate that in one setting we cannot
find a low degree decomposition of small
relations so the short answer is there
are ways and is already there it's kind
of the feeling that we don't know how to
find ways to narrow down the degree it's
not clear it's impossible hope this
gives a brief summary of this this is
great question this happens in order
attack off or the other candidate
candidates in general so let me continue
with in a setting that we see you later
sorry one second to you to follow up on
Rachel's question you're saying that
this attack can be overcome if you if
you sort of repeat the branching Pro
Hughes refer concatenate the branching
program with itself security parameter
number of times right that's what you're
saying but we don't know how to prove
anything about it thought it gives you a
candidate it gives you a candidate IO
which resists these attacks right in
fact I would motivate even an open
problem of how to attack it
he repeated many times yeah we will see
so since we mentioned this let me just
remind you again in the first few in the
first example of program to attack we
actually assume you know
there's X's on where all the integers
are what happened to 1 2 and the reason
where there are other indices which what
firm 1 2 1 2 in the sense we are using
the input partitioning feature what I
was describing before is if you don't
have this equal to partitioning feature
then we need to more complex attack and
at some point the clarity technique
doesn't work okay so let's resume so in
the case that you can partition the
input into two parts so you can organize
this matrix in the following way
by just about listing on other inputs so
right now if you rewrite this equation
into the equation we previously
described like there's a big component X
there's a big component of Z there's
useful information in X what we can do
is a look at W computer is left kernel
and your guarantee that Z is a full rank
with high probability is square so the
left kernel of W is really the left
kernel of next excuse me so after
looking at you computed the left kernel
of X let's see what you can extract so
if you see the left kernel of X so what
you really see is you will see a bunch
of linear relation a linear system of
equations over the boundary scalars and
we are trying to use the homogeneous
feature of these equations to get
possibly the ratio of these scalars this
is what you will get in a certain step
of the attack so here we are almost
close to the first interesting urban
problem so record that to the go of the
mixed import attacks
to learn the schooners and then you can
do the mixing coat attack so something I
haven't told you before is if you put
the juice W in the 2-2 to 15 in the
original setting of digits 15 so say
let's use the ring setting so what you
can get is all the ratios over the like
the fractional idea of where all the
convenience reasons might be big so what
we really want is to get the small
multiples of each of them so at this
moment you know this seems like a easy
problem I would like to remind you this
looks like the entry problem except that
we don't have much Q so we know entry
problem is hard if you have all the easy
stuff and mod Q then getting the small
multiples of each of them it's difficult
but right now we don't have much q they
are stupid seems to be an easy problem
it turns out this problem we also don't
know how to solve and as a time so at
that time we only know you know from
certain parameters because you have
multiple samples you can use averaging
attack but in general you get ratio over
the fractional idea we still need
quantum polynomial time algorithm or
classical sub exponential time algorithm
to find the small multiples of each of
them so this motivates the first
interesting problem I want to tell you
that it's called entry problem without
mod Q so let's say you are given just a
one sample like H equals to F over G
over the rational ring and sorry not a
so it's it can be expressed as a
rational polynomial in a ring so where f
energy
simpler ways small coefficients like
what normal and should do the only
difference is we don't you have it
without mod Q so you get some somehow
even more information
and that the task is to find a small
multiples of f energy so this problem it
turns out not to be easy still even
today it's 2020 I don't know how to
solve them without using quantum yeah so
this is the first interesting problem
and I want to leave I wonder like to
mention that the problem I leave might
be very simple compared to the problems
you see yesterday but you know it turns
out even for this interesting problem we
don't know how to solve and if this
problem turns out to be hard it actually
gives you a candidate where a problem
look like lattices and it's defined over
the integer or rational but we don't
know how to at least a break the
one-wayness
sorry so so try to understand why this
problem is is hard without the mod Q you
can you can write this F over G is a
product of 2 meters to smaller C's write
the matrix that computes the
multiplication by G inverses the G
inverse is actually small over has small
coefficients over the rationals right
the inverse of a small matrix s small
entries as well over the and now you can
write it as G inverse times F rather the
matrix that computes G inverse times
this better of coefficients of that and
you're asking to sort of like do this
decomposition over the sorry ok I see so
you're saying we don't know how to solve
this solve this problem yeah yeah ok all
right yeah
Thanks let's continue so really a quick
summarize of the siege 17 attack is so
you run through a bunch of stab their
linear algebra but in the end you meet a
step which requires quantum in a sub X
donation so really the status of seizure
17 it's a quantum attack because of the
last step so I would say there are two
limitations of the first attack so first
it need a you need quantum polynomial or
sub-exponential classical in the last
step and the attack only applies to
branching programs where the indices can
be partitioned into X's on and Azizah
like first part is or 1/2 1/2
the second part is always 3 4 3 4 so we
can overcome some of them in the in the
second attack and the attack is actually
has much simpler algorithm it's it's
called a rock attack so after you get in
the matrix W so instead of computing the
left corner of W extracting the scalars
make them smaller and then we do the
maximum input attack what we can do is
that's just a directly compute the rank
of W so let's see what's the rank of W
might tell you and there were later
explained what we do so as I mentioned
before you can organize the matrix so
that the decision is high rank with high
probability
so exhume has one arrow component which
is also for rank with high probability
but the rank of this excess component
may leak information about
and this is the fact we have enough make
use of so let's try to find two programs
where this attack can apply so first
let's treat a little bit so let's find
two functional equivalent programs that
it's easy to describe what's the rank
difference if you calculate the rank of
W carefully you will see in the first
case the rank of W depends on a sub
matrix like this in the second program
the rank of W depends on a sub matrix
like this so this is like a rank n this
is a rank two n so now let's find a real
example so in the real example we think
about a like all the inputs are
partitioning into two zones and now they
can like interleaved with it with each
other
so it can be 1 2 1 2 3 4 3 4 1 2 1 2 3 4
3 4 and in the ones who want to place
there will be P and P inverse cancelling
out each other on some input bits so it
turns out for this type of branching
program the attack is the same except is
you organized a matrix W which is a with
much bigger dimension the open M is the
same be just a varied organized a matrix
the only difference is the analysis is
going to be much more complex so in the
analysis we crucially use matrix product
switching trick introducing the work of
a point or in a cone at all
we actually using this trick to extend
attack on CRT searching and the digit 13
multilinear maps roughly speaking it
says if we have a matrix product of four
matrices you can rewrite them into the
way that a and a C can be output into a
vector in the left and B and ID you can
be outputting a vector in the right it's
just the dimension blows up
in the end in the ranked attack you will
see program one case look like this the
program to case look like this this
gesture M is a bigger matrix depends on
P which is very complex but there you
can see the relative difference and in
general you can use this index switching
attack to switch back in indices which
are you know interleaving to something
which is partitioning in general in the
index repeat for C times the dimension
of the matrix accumulate has to be 2 to
the 2 times C so really if you repeat
for constant times Chris to attack if
you repeat force security parameter many
times then the matrix will collect in
the attack is also exponential damage I
want to end this talk by a quick remark
that you can also use this attack to
break or the PRF from matrix products I
think I'm shorting time let me tell you
the result if we'd have a matrix product
PRF from other interleaving products so
then actually you can break them in time
to to the C we are see it's the time of
repetition of the indices in this work
we also provide a single proof of the
matrix switch dilemma at this moment I
would like to remind another interesting
problem that so this problem I have
started sinking for less number of
period of time it's only started
recently so can we show a better attack
for matrix PRF bio using quantum arisen
so briefly on the background so we also
know some content advantage in solving
linear algebra problem so if the matrix
satisfies some tricky conditions then
you can serve linear algebra of a matrix
who is actually exponential dimension in
polynomial time so although this depends
on how do you represent the matrix and
also how do we depend represent or the
input-output
the vectors you can also modify the
algorithm in different ways to come up
with an algorithm that decides whether
the rank of input matrix is super high
or super low again the running time
depends on a lot of conditions in the
matrix like other singular values etc so
what is this algorithm useful for so if
you can show that some kind of the
quantum algorithm which decides the rank
of a matrix is widely employed then you
might be able to apply it order matrix
branching programs that represents a PRF
obtained from parent in serum in fact we
have such a candidate not a candidate in
some sense in the work of Mark here has
already proved that the NC 1pf from
analysis is secure in the quantum query
model so it's really interesting to
understand the connection between the
possible quantum algorithm of deciding
the rank and you know the security of
this PRF computable in c1 and the
presumably quantum secure so I'd like to
wrap up my talk so this is the status of
order IO candidates under the framework
of cogito
so still under the current understanding
if you repeat the branch and program for
super polynomial sorry
security parameter many times oh you use
the dual input branching program we
don't know any attacks of these setting
in fact we don't know a quantum attack
specifically for digit
and in the walk of cvw 18 we provide
another variant of the obfuscation
candidate where there are two
differences so first we emphasize on the
oblivious parent program has to repeat
the indices for n times and then we make
the bundling factors as non-competitive
it turns out you can do so so this is
attacked
using statistical tag by showing at all
but we can fix it by changing the
parameters and I would like to conclude
this talk by you know we first the two
urban problems maybe they can solve
within a day the first problem is entry
problem without mark you the other is
think about better rank attack using
quantum algorithms is it's the end of
the talk I can take questions wait out
of time maybe we can just take one quick
question yeah so I have a quick question
yeah yeah just on the open problem slide
so just one slide before so H in it's
already a small multiple effect you
wanted something even smaller than that
ah so it turns out it depends on how do
you represent edge over Q X over Phi X
so let me give you a high level picture
of what possibly there was the possible
representation of it so think about you
get an edge in the following form you
know all the coefficients are in
rational so you can represent it in a
very stupid way that all the
denominators are the big common
denominators so it can be as large as
the norm of G so if you are giving edge
in that way and this is what you are
actually obtained in the experiment it's
actually not clear how to find a small
representative in both
the denominator and the denominator so
it depends on the representation you get
for edge the most convenient way is to
think about that representation so if
you get in that representation how to
find a small one it's not August okay so
since we're out of time
let's take all four the questions of
line let's thank the speaker again